If you were to give a TED Talk (or if you already have), what ideas would you present?
So, my advice to the next generation
is find situations where you get to give a TED Talk.
It may not be an official TED Talk,
it may be at a TEDx,
it may be at another conference,
or it mayb e just an opportunity to give a talk,
and you should treat it as if it is a TED Talk.
And the way it's become so cheap, so easy
to do high-quality video,
not only is it easy to video,
but you can put it in this infrastructure called YouTube
and other people can see it
(the architecture of the Internet
allows for this video to move)
that when you give an awesome talk,
it's a way to put part of you out there.
And the process of preparing for a TED Talk,
I mean, it's like Mary Lou Retton
getting a perfect ten in the Olympics.
Now I'm dating myself,
but when I was little,
this little lady just ran as hard as she could
and went over a pole vault,
and it was just perfect.
And I think someone, Nadia Comaneci,
did the same thing the generation before,
but I don't remember that one,
I don't know if I was even alive.
But have a few situations where you do a ten
and share that with your network
and ask.
And in the process of preparing for your talk,
ask for advice.
Go to tons of different people.
Go to people who have different perspectives
and get their feedback.
And while part of the reason you want their feedback
is because you want to do a great talk,
another part is you're building a rapport.
You're building your board of advisors.
You're building your community.
And by telling people what your talk's about,
it also helps you shape yourself
and kind of determine what's important to you.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.